[Music]
in next level identity-theft news oh
damn
nice level man submitted by a lone Sloan
Sloan come over here a woman has been
accused of poisoning her look-alike to
steal her identity oh oh why does her
life suck that much yeah Megan Fox
trying to do that to me once I was like
damn Megan Fox you trying to be a
youtuber Daniel Henney try to steal my
identity oh he wanted to learn how to
cook huh yeah that's what my and her
name is Victoria she's a Russian native
but she fled to New York in 2014 after
allegedly killing another woman oh [ __ ]
and then she seduced the lead detective
in her prosecution and that's was like a
movie
this is sounds like a movie do is she
[ __ ] hot oh that's not the Russian ah
yeah Alfie more blonde she looks like
she could be a Guido yeah she's still
pretty good-looking this is what I was
thinking in like Angelina Jolie insult
wait wait she blow on assault no no okay
yeah yeah how old is she she's a little
ready to she just look like a regular
lady like a DMV photo here's like a
selfie of it okay yeah she looks like
the Pussycat lead singer Nicole
Scherzinger gosh don't say that that's
my culture that is fuzzy gave a tainted
cheesecake to paint I just heard tank
okay meat you know how do you say that
last name
so thank ya so she gave her the
cheesecake and then once she passed out
cuz the inside the cheesecake I like
tranquilizers oh [ __ ] and then once she
passed out she stole all her her
identification stuff like her paperwork
and money and jewelry
everything and then she left her on her
bed where the whole bunch of pills
spread around her trying to make it seem
like she committed suicide but luckily
she woke up she was taken to the
hospital she's okay
damn and so now this crazy ass is now
she's been arrested yeah but maybe in
the United States of an Americans all
she needed was like her indentification
so I was like the Russian swatter
something become America grab her ass
out and throw her ass back in Russia uh
well she is in jail here
what kind actually you know what I just
caught myself let's continue because I
was gonna talk about food and you're
gonna make fun of me so let's go don't
deny us that come on David kind of food
they are pierogies Russian no I think
they're German okay never mind
well I may be wrong because the only
thing I've had a Russian food is well I
had like this fancy Russian food place
it tasted really good but apparently
that's not like traditional as
traditional as it's supposed to be so
what I ate was really good but like
traditional Russian food doesn't taste
that great I hear like borscht
yeah like borscht soup like it's just
this beet soup and then they have like a
lot of pickled like finish and [ __ ] like
that I do want to try Russia frienda
really trying to do Russian because I
had pickled herring pickled herring in
the airport because I had pickled
herring - but it was done different
there was like hard-boiled eggs there
was like like sour cream and chives like
potato salad with beets and then pickled
herring and it was put into a remould
she was [ __ ] boss that sounds good
that's apparently not how it's done I
feel like Russia's just [ __ ] drink
vodka and eat sturgeon it's too cold
there in caviar
yeah there's no like there's no life so
I'm thinking like okay beets and [ __ ]
out there what are you what's your
favorite like Russian they eat dumplings
I saw that they have staff dumplings
like it looks like big shaolin balls oh
really
I did watch this one chefs table where
they said they spent some time in Russia
with like a Russian Michelin star
restaurant and the chef was explaining
because of like the whole communism
thing like culinary evolution wasn't
stressed oh so a lot of their food he
was like I admit it kind of sucks ass
compared to like the rest of the world
because it's been able to evolve but
what he's doing he is trying to go back
and
of going forward and just adapting like
French style or Italian style he's going
back to the roots and then reviving that
and he was like serving like moose
tongue [ __ ] like that he's that guy oh
dude that episode there's one part that
made me laugh super hard so he's like
talking to this moose right beautiful
customer see where the Moose is spaces
yeah it was just like he's like oh nice
moose and they're like and he's like
they're milking [ __ ] moose milk and it
just looked like he's got a petting zoo
yeah and he's like heartwarming and
immediately it cuts to a silver platter
with buck like moose head eyeball
[ __ ] tunnel is a Russian cake that's
really good it's like a hundred layers
or something like that it's like a bunch
of layers and it takes a long time to
make I first like the Russian dolls they
do the cake the same way it's like one
after the other the past times about
yeah I had at one time at my friend
who's Russia and that was her birthday
cake and it was really and mine was
delicious yeah it was really good it was
homemade would like a flavor it's kind
of like a light tiramisu but like in a
bunch of layers we gotta go check out
some Russian food we gotta go I'm pretty
sure you have a tour guide out there
oh go all the way to Russia gonna get it
big all right community out in like what
Glendale or that the valley area yeah
yeah because Armenians and Glendale or
there's a Russian Russian - yeah yeah
you just gotta go to a place where like
all the ends are backwards yeah that's
the Russian wait so did the detective
get in trouble yeah he go to jail
she definitely suck his dick I know he's
getting in trouble she sucks and that's
how he was able to get away or she was
able to get away
and then when she got to Brooklyn
they're saying that she enjoyed a lavish
lifestyle of diamonds and furs because
she stole seventeen thousand dollars in
cash and jewelry from her first victim
and then when she got to New York she
would just seduce men and then Shalu
she's very okay look people I mean they
might be sixteen-year-old and also men
it doesn't take much guys
that's true I would not be seduced by
that really well you're different
because hot girls come up to you and
you're annoyed by them but like most
guys like it like even if attractive
woman is just like kind of interested in
them they're like yeah just too much
grease on her forehead to seduce me it
just reminds me of Michael too much like
it's just like that shiny for it is like
yeah you remind me of Mike but that was
a mugshot that was like a DMV photo
nobody looks good in those she has bad
choice in earrings I'm like defending
her I think she's seducing like older
Steve yeah yeah these guys aren't like
Brad Pitt they're not like super hot
there's like any lonely guy that doesn't
get attention from women what [ __ ]
love to see yeah exactly yeah I mean I
mean for me I'm still young I just be
like no you want something from me yeah
I've already got a girlfriend [ __ ] I
don't need a heart I roll you go Joe
yeah your hands I am no [ __ ] Matt
Paul
nah this she's older and you yeah if you
were 70 you'll be like oh you made me
feel young again she looks good yes
it's really good that's just not his
taste lady number two yeah maybe just
not my taste nobody [ __ ] with it though
that's not his taste what if you found
out she like fed a village of a thousand
hungry children or instead of murdered
somebody
no don't make me horny that'll make me
horny though yeah I think murdering
somebody said like when a guy sees a
girl in our mind she goes to Harvard
like if she's already hot
we already complete the backstory um so
her backstory is she's over a cauldron
with killing children I'm not into that
okay yep I think she would probably get
[ __ ] you're way prettier than her
Nicky that's what I'm saying
so I go to Harvard yes you go to Harvard
yeah that never worked on me know how
girls or girls trying to get [ __ ] out of
you
yeah I love the money more than [ __ ]
for sure
I can't I'll be I'm the kind of guy at
the strip club waiting for the [ __ ]
two for one song special I'm getting a
discount his lips pierced too like while
he's waiting like everything's inside of
you though my knees more important than
a lap dance
mmm give me the deer gave me the
discount all right this two-for-one
specials on now I could take that lap
dance you do pole dancers get paid more
than strippers cuz pole dancing is way
harder what's the difference I don't
know the pole do the ones where they
swing and they keep the upper body
strength aren't those strippers I'm
talking about the athletes because
that's different one is like because if
you're talking about if they're both
working at the same Spearmint Rhino or
whatever yeah they're both strippers
it's just one has more Skills than the
other one you can hone your skills
definitely the pole desert should get
paid more on a base scale cuz that [ __ ]
is [ __ ] are you talking about lap
dancing versus pole dancing
no just pulled that together I thought
they're just two separate people no that
is okay if you're at the strip club I
love if you're at the strip club this is
what happens okay oh I never be strip
club so that's why oh well okay so so
there's actual pole dancers that aren't
strippers they're athletes
why only
not their top right no they don't take
anything off and they don't work at the
store like suck people yeah you know
those people that are in robes and [ __ ]
that Wow
oh I know what you're talking about yeah
acrobats the difference it's just
athletic like pole dancing no work a
stripper and then you have actual strip
clubs where they have pole dancing and
all that stuff and what usually happens
is the girl this year comes sparkles and
then she has her song just like it's
[ __ ] I don't know like one of those
stripper songs like [ __ ] vanity six
nasty girl or whatever and she goes on
stage she does the dance that is so
tight if she's white it's probably gonna
be some like ac/dc or whatever and if
she's black it's gonna be like you know
like genuine pony yeah or whatever and
if she's Asian
is it geisha she has come very slowly
like dude there was this Asian chicken
egg Jumbo's that we all need to go to
Jumbo's is awesome with jumbo like a
burlesque club but they do pole dancing
and they have a lot of like cool skills
so burlesque is like they don't strip
completely naked but they strip down to
their like bra and underwear yeah but
there was this asian chick there who was
so tight she came out to metal and she
was scary as [ __ ] she's like go to the
audience place the cover gloves
oh it's tight cuz each stripper there
has like a way different personality and
a theme yeah and that's kind of like the
strip club thing and then after that
they make their real money on lap dances
so the pole dancing and the stripping is
like hey hey this is who I am yeah you
like me and then afterwards they come up
you wanna dance
so appetizer and then you go pay like 20
bucks or something yeah and you get your
dick rubbed
[Music]